good afternoon everyone
happy Friday and I got the date right
today the day right today
Friday the 13th oh well
it's gonna be a little crazy in here
okay
um as this week comes to a close I want
to take a moment to highlight the
incredible progress the president has
made for the American people in recent
days from expanding Affordable Health
Care to lowering costs and tackling
inflation to Bringing manufacturing and
jobs back to our Shores President Biden
started the week at the North American
leaders Summit in Mexico City where he
spoke for for two hour close cooperation
with Mexico and Canada to address shared
challenges that impact the American
people challenges like combating climate
change covid-19 pandemic and
transnational criminal organizations
that are trafficking and smuggling
people as well as illicit drugs like
fentanyl
the president spoke to our work to take
thousands of Smugglers off the streets
catch record levels of fentanyl before
it even reaches our border strengthen
border security and increase resources
for Border communities all over the all
over the opposition of Republican
Governors and Republican members of
Congress I might add
we've also continued taking action to
lower health care costs for American
families made possible by President
Biden and Congressional Democrats
enactment of the inflation reduction act
on Wednesday HHS announced its historic
plans for Medicaid for Medicare to
directly negotiate negotiate lower
prescription drug costs in addition
starting this month seniors on Medicare
are seeing their insulin costs capped at
35 dollars for a month's Supply they are
also now able to get recommended
vaccines for free all of this thanks to
again the inflation reduction act HHS
also announced record-breaking
enrollment number of Health Care
coverage on the Affordable Health Care
Act Marketplace nearly 16 million people
have signed up for this open enrollment
period for Health Care coverage a 13
increase from last year
and it includes over three million
people who are who are brand new to the
marketplace and we're not even done with
the Open Enrollment yet because of the
cost savings measure in the inflation
reduction act that the that President
Biden signed into law millions of
Americans are continuing to save eight
hundred dollars per year on health
insurance on average and four out of the
five healthcare.gov enrollees can can
find coverage for ten dollars or less a
month all of this adds up to real to
real impact and meaningful uh progress
to expand affordable quality Health Care
coverage for American families and that
matters that matters to the American
people we also had exciting news on the
economic front as well on Wednesday as
you all saw the largest solar investment
in U.S history a direct result of the
president's economic plan and the
inflation reduction act again this 2.5
billion dollars investment in Georgia
will create 2 500 jobs and yesterday we
learned that for the six month in a row
inflation has indeed come down annual
inflation has fallen to lowest level
since October of 2021 and gas prices are
down by more than a dollar seventy cents
from their Peak thanks in part to the
president's actions to increase oil
supply which were also historic actions
that this president took this is further
proof the president's economic plan is
working even though inflation is high in
most major economies it's coming down in
America and giving families more
Breathing Room you hear the president
say that all the time how he wants to
make sure that he's giving American
families a little bit more of a
breathing room at the same time the
president is building an economy from
the bottom up and middle out with the
lowest unemployment rate in 50 years
nearly 11 million jobs created and
historic manufacturing investment like I
just mentioned totaling nearly 300
billion dollars in major Investments
across the country and as of as we end
this week on Friday the 13th as somebody
marked
today President Biden welcomed Prime
Minister kashida of Japan to the White
House we will have a joint statement out
for all of you shortly laying out of
their conversation and their discussion
this afternoon but I can tell you that
the two leaders are discussing the
unprecedented actions we have taken
together to better equip us for the 21st
century challenges as well as working to
deepen our cooperation on everything
from economics to technology to fighting
the climate crisis advancing peace and
stability in the indo-pacific and around
the world today's visit is a testament
to President Biden's investment in our
alliances and Partnerships since day one
since he walked into the administration
and a historic week is leading into a
historic weekend I am so happy and glad
to be joined by my colleague and former
mayor of Atlanta senior advisor for
public engagement Keisha Lance bottoms
to talk about the president's trip this
coming Sunday to the historic Ebenezer
their Baptist Church to remember and
honor the legacy of Dr Martin Luther
King Jr this Sunday as I just said I
know many of you had some interest here
so we wanted to make sure that she was
here to answer any questions and to lay
out why this day is going to be so
important I do want to say on a personal
note as black women we have broken
barriers this church and the day
honoring King are near and dear to both
of our hearts I know on a personal level
we are both looking forward to joining
the president on this trip and being in
what has been the epicenter of the
movement from civil rights in this
country for decades with that my hair
bottles
okay the floor is yours thank you
well good afternoon everyone
it's kind of scary up here right
Karine mentioned I am looking forward to
joining the president
um as he travels to Atlanta this weekend
um as you many of you all know and Dr
King's I Have a Dream speech uh he
expressed many ideals that he would not
live to witness but I stand here and
many of you sit out there as
beneficiaries of that dream his
sacrifice and service so I am eternally
grateful for that as Kareem mentioned
the president is traveling to Atlanta
this is at the invitation of Reverend
Warnock and the president will deliver a
sermon at Ebenezer Church which of
course was Dr King's church also
congressman John Lewis's Church the
president spoke with Senator Warnock
Last Night senator Warnock has been the
pastor since 2005 at Ebenezer they had a
wonderful conversation about the
significance of this historic event
include including the fact that the
president is the first sitting president
to speak at a Sunday service at Ebenezer
in its history this would have been Dr
King's 94th birthday as we know this is
an inflection point in history and the
president will deliver remarks
reflecting on Dr King's Life and Legacy
and the way that we can go forward
together following his trip to Atlanta
on Sunday he will join Reverend Al
Sharpton on Monday at the National
Action Network which Monday of course is
the day the official Celebration Day of
the Kink holiday the president will
deliver the keynote speech there and
then finally before I take any questions
this is an important day as a member of
Delta Sigma Theta sorority Incorporated
it's our Founders Day our 110th founders
day so the president uh did a lovely
video for the women of Delta also our
secretary of Hud Marsha Fudd was also a
former National president of Delta so
the president the Vice President are
very grateful for all of the support of
the women of Delta and the divine nine
and happy Founders Day
all right we'll take a couple questions
okay
can I ask you if uh if you're as in your
role in community outreach whether the
issue of the documents is a particular
setback for the president at a moment
when other things seem to be going
pretty well inflation is coming down
employment is solid like are you finding
that you're getting a lot of response
from the public on that and how do you
how do you play that issue and my role
as senior advisor for public engagement
we've not gotten any information on that
in terms of from the public we've not
received any questions if you anticipate
that that will have any bearing or is
causing the president to think at all
about it as he's making his decision
about whether to run again will this um
series of
discoveries have any bearing on his
thinking and his thought process
I'll refer those questions to the
president he can speak for himself on
that
while the president's in Atlanta what do
you expect his message to be on voting
rights in particular and given that this
situation in the Senate remains
virtually unchanged when he spoke about
this issue in Atlanta last year is he
considering any additional executive
action in this issue while the president
has been very clear that we need
Congress to act he's asked for congress
uh to codify the John Lewis Voting
Rights Act and also the additional
Voting Rights Act that's pending uh
before Congress sets the freedom to vote
acts so the president has been very
clear that voting the right to vote the
access to vote is a core a component of
our democracy and he's going to continue
to push for that including on Sunday at
the church the president will speak on a
number of issues at the church including
how important it is that we have access
to our democracy and you can't come to
Atlanta and not acknowledge the role
that the civil rights movement that Dr
King played and where we are in the
history of our country but we still have
to push forward we still have more work
to do and just one other thing do you
expect him to have any engagement with
the King Family while he's down there we
do expect that I know in on previous
Sundays previous King Day services and
many Sundays prior to the pandemic Dr
King's sister in particular is often at
the service I don't know if she will be
there this Sunday and we also expect
other members of The King Family to be
there as well
regards to the the Voting Rights uh you
know last time he had last time around
this time when when President Biden went
to Atlanta some of the civil rights
groups and voting rights groups uh
skipped the speech
out of concern that the White House
wasn't doing enough to push this issue
aside from wanting Congress to do more
what uh what is the message to those
um who feel the White House is not
giving it up well as I've been in this
role a senior advisor to the president
since June of last year we have engaged
with civil rights leaders he's had them
at the White House in a round table I'm
in constant contact with them and I
think that it's very clear that the
president is doing everything that he
can in his executive power to lean in on
voting rights but we need Congress to do
more this is important if you've come
through the East Wing you've seen the
pictures of Dr King meeting with Lyndon
Johnson meeting with other civil rights
leaders hashing out voting rights in the
White House and so the fact that we are
still here talking about this in 2023 I
think really speaks to the fact that we
need action we need that action from
Congress the president has done and will
continue to do all that he can do in his
executive powers but there's only so
much that he can do we need Congress to
act
is it the feeling then that that he is
he has exhausted what he can do his
powers from the White House his
executive house well if there is more
that he can do we welcome those
suggestions but as I stand here today
it's my understanding that we have done
all that we can do from the executive
branch now we need Congress to act
yeah thank you so much for being here
really appreciate it
um when you look at the economy you saw
the unemployment rate come down last
month and yet it went up for black women
for Latinos what is your reaction how
focused is this Administration I'm
trying to make sure that the recovery is
equal is helping African-American women
well Equity is at the center of what we
do from this Administration and so
that's extremely important um you know
it's been said that when America catches
a coal then Black America catches the
flu well that's also in relation to the
economy we often know that communities
of color in those communities and that
often face additional challenges have
additional challenges with the economy
the great news is that the economy is
doing much better under this
Administration also the president is
going to continue to lean in to make
sure that we have access access to
resources that are specific to
communities of color that are specific
to women to give us those opportunities
to be successful in this economy
participate in addressing that in his
remarks on
I know that he
normally as
where we are just in terms of helping
those who are in need in our communities
I don't know if he will specifically
address the economy but as you all know
during Dr King's last major campaign
before his assassination it was called
the Poor People's campaign and what we
know is that from this Administration
many of the focused areas have been
aligned with Dr with what Dr King was
focused on at the time of his
assassination that's making sure that we
are creating this Beloved Community free
from hate free from poverty giving
people access to resources so that they
can have what they need to compete and
succeed
thank you thinking back to the 2020
campaign
um part of the president's strategy at
the time was going to visit these
churches to engage some of the voters
that he needed to turn out for him in
South Carolina there was the 16th Street
a bombing anniversary they spoke at in
Alabama and also on hand in Selma for
bloody Sunday because this speech at
Ebenezer at the start of a similar
Outreach campaign heading into 2024.
um I don't know that it's the start of
it but it could be a great start of it
um I know that the president
is very interested in connecting with
people hearing directly from people it's
the best way that any elected official
truly hears and understands the needs of
people and there's no better place than
to do that than at Ebenezer uh Reverend
Warnock has not just been very vocal
about the challenges and the issues that
are facing people as a candidate but
also as a pastor in Ebenezer is a
Cornerstone in the Atlanta community and
I'm sure the president will get an
earful on on what our needs and our
desires are for our country when he's
there can you provide any insight into
the writing
to write for the speech
uh pay attention to speeches like this
about how long the president's been
working on it for we've been working on
it for a couple of weeks just as a team
and and of course with the president's
input and as with any major speech that
the president is giving you he gives his
input and and the team takes it from
there and then he takes his pin and and
he says what he wants to say and um
you'll hear that on Sunday
the weather
is it finished no
um okay
okay all right just one question uh
obviously Democrats had a big victory in
the runoff election uh in Georgia he's
going back to historic black institution
uh to speak to this church you know how
do you see the state uh your home state
kind of fit into the political landscape
going forward now Georgia is pretty
important I think the whole I've always
thought that now the rest of the country
knows it we know that that Georgia has
played an important role with how our
Senate is is now comprised and I expect
that that role will continue to be just
as important in future election Cycles
and and remember sorry uh I just have to
say this uh Georgia did go for Joe Biden
all right
last question
um just a couple of questions first of
whether it be
um on uh Monday or on Sunday when he's
in Ebenezer is he going to be meeting
with any civil rights organizations at
any point
um during any of those visits well as I
mentioned on Monday he will be joining
Reverend Al at the National Action
Network there'll be many civil rights
representatives there there will be many
um at the church who will also have an
opportunity to connect with the
president while he's there nothing
separately nothing separately but there
will be some engagement while at the
church and the policy Forum with
Reverend Sharpton when he attends the
the event
um what kind of policy can you talk
about that you know that they'll be
talking about on that on that day or
what for what kind of policies do you
think that we can kind of expect to hear
the president talk about even following
that I know that rev has been talking
about Criminal Justice Reform quite a
lot and had several other meetings can
we see the president and pick back up on
those same messages following this well
the great thing is that this is not a
one-time engagement Reverend Al and some
of the other civil rights leaders I
believe from eight other organizations
were in the White House a few months ago
sitting down with the president sharing
their concerns we my office me
personally I'm constantly
engaged with these civil rights leaders
so we're hearing in real time what our
challenges are and I I think I can
safely say that we have confidence many
of these leaders that we are doing what
we can do and will continue to do more
as we can to make sure that the needs of
our communities are met
foreign
okay thanks everybody and thank you so
much Keisha
appreciate it
um I have a couple things
at the top and I just want to go through
this is the week ahead so all of you
have this
um so uh before we take questions
so later today the president's gonna
travel to Wilmington Delaware as you all
know on Sunday as you just heard from
mayor Lance bottoms the president will
travel to Atlanta Georgia and deliver a
sermon at Ebenezer Baptist Church and on
Monday he will return to Washington DC
to join Reverend Al Sharpton and the
national the National Action Network at
their Martin Luther King Jr Day
breakfast where he will deliver the
keynote address on Tuesday the president
looks forward to welcoming prime
minister Mark Ruta of the Netherlands to
the White House to further deepen the
historic ties between our two Nations as
strong NATO allies and Global Partners
the two leaders will reaffirm our shared
efforts to strengthen transatlantic
security and economic Prosperity after
that bilateral meeting the president
will welcome the Golden State Warriors
to the White House to celebrate their
2022 NBA championship and next Friday
the president will welcome bipartisan
Mayors attending the U.S comp Conference
of mayor's winter meeting to to the
White House the president will deliver
remarks celebrating the achievements of
the past 18 months and focusing on the
bipartisan work that needs to be done to
implement these and other historic
pieces of legislative victories at the
level at the local level to make
difference to make a difference in
people's lives across the country with
that Chris you want to take us off sure
a question on a couple different topics
speaker McCarthy's invited the president
to deliver the State of the Union on
February 7th I think this went out uh is
that the date that the president plans
to give this to the union does he accept
it so we have received speaker
McCarthy's kind invitation and the
president has accepted it it and looks
forward to delivering the State of the
Union Address on Tuesday February 17th
of 2023. so we
oh my God I'm so sorry guys on Tuesday
February 7th
2023 but we truly appreciate the kind
invitation by Speaker McCarthy on the uh
debt limit uh Republicans want to cut
spending as part of a development deal
is the president willing to cut any
spending as part of the limit deal and
nobody be willing to cut look as you've
heard us uh say before uh we will not be
uh be doing any negotiation over the
debt ceiling and uh but broadly speaking
at the start of this new Congress we're
reaching out to all the members through
the office of ledge Affairs making sure
that they making sure that we have those
connections with those new members as I
just stated but I want to say like in
the past and I've said this before and
I'll say it again there's been a
bipartisan cooperation when it comes to
lifting the debt ceiling and that's how
it should be that's how we should
continue it's not it's not and should
not be a political football this is not
political gamemanship and we are there's
this should be done without conditions
and that's how we see this process
moving forward you say that there'll be
no negotiating not negotiate anything
involving spending what we're saying is
that there should be this should be done
without conditions in the past we have
seen this uh we have seen uh both
Republicans and Democrats come together
uh to deal with this issue it is a it is
one of the basic items that Congress has
to deal with and which should be done
without conditions so there is going to
be uh there's going to be no negotiation
over it this is something that must get
done and uh does the president agree
with the secretary treasury secretary
that that ceiling should be eliminated
again I've spoken to this before that is
not uh no one is talking about
eliminating the debt ceiling or does the
debt limit that's not what we're talking
right about right now uh Congress is is
going to need to raise the debt limit
without condition so that is not what
the discussion that we're having very
last thing have White House specials
been interviewed by the special counsel
or by the justice department uh
involving the classified doctor so what
I'll say from here is uh any any
questions that you we may have about the
review about the process I would refer
you to the Department of Justice I would
also refer you to my colleagues over at
the White House Council I'm not going to
get into any specifics from here
okay Mary aside from the special counsel
aside from this review I just have a
question about processing classified
documents in their handling because I
think there's some confusion I'm going
to the public and even in this room what
is the process to make sure the
classified documents aren't accidentally
or intentionally taken when a president
or vice president leaves office you know
what's the protocol or is this sort of
just you know a self review system it's
a good question I would on the process
and how that works I would I would
certainly refer you to the White House
counsel's office they would know that
they can walk you through that my
colleagues there uh and and I know many
of you have been uh have been in touch
with my colleagues in the last 24 hours
in direct touch and answering many of
your questions so I would refer you to
them on the specific process so that
they will they will certainly uh guide
you in the right way and but as far as
you know is it ever okay for classified
documents to be mixed with personal what
I can say uh look what I can say is what
the president has said before what I
have said multiple times we take this
very seriously the president takes a
classified information classified
documents very seriously but look you
know I've said this I've said this
before we have addressed this issue
multiple times at length and we have
been fully cooperating with the
Department of Justice and now we will be
doing the same with the special
counsel's office out of just to be
prudent here and just to make sure that
we are consistent I would refer you
anything that is related to this to the
as it relates to the review to
Department of Justice or my colleagues
at the White House Council Office and
this is we see it as the best way to
move forward we want to respect the
process and so that's what I'm going to
do I'm going to refer you to Department
of Justice here you're confident that
you follow whatever protocol was in
place again this is something that he
takes very seriously uh the president
when it comes to classified documents
when it comes to classified information
I'm not going to go into any specifics
from here if you have any questions
anything further that's related to the
review or I refer you to the Department
of Justice or my colleagues over at the
White House counsel's Office who I know
many of you who I'm staring at right now
has been in close touch good a few
things Doreen thank you following up on
the State of the Union I believe it was
the president who suggested he has
spoken with speaker McCarthy is there
any plans for them to meet in person
yeah they spoke and I think we actually
share that with all of you the day that
speaker McCarthy became speaker you you
heard you saw a statement from the
president and the first lady
congratulating
congratulating Kevin McCarthy becoming
speaker and then the next day I believe
it was that was on a Friday I believe
the next day which was a Saturday the
president had a direct conversation he
connected uh with speaker McCarthy and
congratulated him in in person I don't
have I don't have a plan I don't have a
uh a scheduled meeting to share with you
at this time I wanted to follow up on a
few things from yesterday when was the
president informed about the attorney
general's decision to appoint a special
counsel how and by who so I the
specifics on that I can tell here's what
I can tell you I can tell you that we
were not giving a heads up I was asked
that question yesterday we did not know
that that was the announcement was going
to come yesterday until after it
happened so I can clear the deck there
and let you know anything else specific
to uh when the president knew or
anything that's related to this I would
refer you to the White House counsel's
office I know many of you that I'm
looking at right now has been in close
touch with my colleague there uh and uh
and so I would continue to refer you to
uh to my colleague at the White House
counsel's Office one of the things that
they finally confirmed for us is that
Bob Bauer is indeed the president's
personal attorney handling some of this
uh given that the justice department
cited the personal Council as having
made this uh initial Outreach to
National Archives and that has been in
touch with the justice department is
that the person who these questions
should be directed to why the White
House counsel
I will say this again I would whatever
the White House counsel my colleague
told you in your conversation I know you
guys just spoke or connected earlier
today I would ask them that question and
anything related to the review I would
refer you to the Department of Justice
and um regarding the
Extraordinary Measures that the treasury
secretary announced a little while ago
and advanced notice to Congress is there
a policy that requires her to give
advance notice of those plans you would
have to you have to reach out to the
Department of Treasury on how that
process works what I can say is uh just
so that everyone knows that folks who
are watching the debt limit is projected
to be reached on Thursday January 19th
at that point treasury will begin to
take Extraordinary Measures to prevent
default secretary yellin did not name a
specific X date if you will the day
treasury would know the day treasury
would no longer be able to pay the
government's obligations but quoting
from the secretary's letter it's
unlikely that that cash and
extraordinated marriage measures will be
exhausted before early June but does
that does not mean that Congress should
not wait until then to raise the debt
ceiling as we have been saying over and
over again the sooner Congress acts the
better since even the prospect of not
raising the debt ceiling will have
damage uh the Full Faith and the credit
of our nation and again we are going to
continue to uh to encourage Congress to
act but as far as the steps and and how
this all works I would refer to the
Department of Treasury six days till the
19th a few years ago she did it about 10
days before I I understand I would refer
you to Department of Treasury nothing to
it being announced today amid the
situation
I would refer you to Department of
Treasury and just to be very clear here
uh Ed we have I've been in here almost
every day since we got back from Mexico
City standing here taking your questions
at length so that we're not avoiding
anything here and we've heard you've
heard you've heard from the president it
at least twice and you we have put forth
multiple statements from the White House
council's office so that suggestion I
just disagree with go ahead Kristin
thank you so much does the White House
and does the president agree to fully
cooperate with the special counsel
investigation we have said that we are
going to continue to continue to fully
cooperate we have been uh the
president's lawyers and team has been
fully cooperating with the Department of
Justice and we're certainly they're
certainly going to do that with the
special counsel and so by that reasoning
would the president agree to sit for an
on the record in person just not I'm not
going to get into to specifics or get
ahead of what's going to happen I'm not
going to get into hypotheticals because
that is a hypothetical what I will say
is we have addressed this multiple times
at length and we are going to continue
the president's team is going to
continue to fully cooperate with the
Department of Justice and we respect
that process and that's what we're going
to do the president has said he hopes to
speak about this soon when can people
expect to hear from but don't have again
that's a that is that is something that
I can't I don't have a magic wand here I
don't know when that's going to happen
what I can say is his team is going to
fully cooperate with the Department of
Justice uh let's not forget the
president said during the campaign that
when it comes to the Department of
Justice Independence he respects that
and that is something that he had said
was incredibly important to make sure
that they had their independence that's
why we say we're going to make sure that
they have their independence and that's
why I'm saying that we're going to refer
to Department of Justice and and let me
just ask you a big picture question here
does the White House broadly speaking
have an obligation to share not just
with the National Archives but with the
American people when the existence of
classified information is found in the
private location again there is a
process
in this but just big picture not
necessarily this instance but is is it
the policy of the White House that they
should share that information not just
with the National Archives but with the
American so I I'll say this Kristen we
have been transparent in the last couple
of days in remember there's an ongoing
process and we have spoken when it is
appropriate and we have shared again
I've been here almost every day not
every day but from Wednesday yesterday
and today taking your questions on this
the White House Council has put out a
very extensive multiple statements on
this as well and you all I know you all
have been talking many of you here have
been talking to my colleague in the
White House Council so what the the
um the actions that we took were right
right actions that his team took uh
indeed in in dealing with the Department
of Justice and also the archives look I
have I have answered questions when the
Press has broken in the news because
it's an ongoing process because again it
is an ongoing process there is a process
here the Department of Justice is
independent we respect that process but
again I have taken questions I can take
two two questions through 100 questions
I have answered your questions uh as
almost every day on this issue and again
anything else that you may have anything
that's related to the review I would
refer to the Department of Justice
question because I know you've got to
move on here but the president
campaigned on the argument that he was
we know that he's in the process of
deciding whether to officially announce
he's running for re-election does this
episode undercut that argument that he
would restore confidence because here we
have in the headlines that he is now
under investigation he's restored
Independence in the Department of
Justice that's what we're doing here
when we're saying we're going to refer
you to the Department of Justice that is
restoring Independence as it as it
relates to issues like this and that is
important to the president and it's been
consistent what I am saying about
investigations has been consistent for
the last two years you've heard me over
and over again when it comes to a legal
issue or matter like this we have always
referred to the Department of Justice so
there's nothing here different here we
have said we wanted to restore the
independence of the Department of
Justice that that is what you're seeing
and again we this has been done in a
transparent way when it relates to how
this was dealt with with the Department
of Justice and the archives the
president takes this very very seriously
any other questions that you may have
about this particular issue about the
review I would refer to Department of
Justice you guys have been in touch with
my colleagues at the White House Council
Office and I would uh suggest that you
continue to reach out go ahead Stephen
thanks I just want to pressure on that
point about the idea of disclosures when
it's appropriate you describe a new
process but it sort of feels like a
strategy a communication strategy to
protect the president from political
damage was it the hope and expectation
here that this would have remained A
Private Matter and not have been subject
to public disclosure look Steven that's
your version of the case I've been very
clear here and I've answered that
question multiple times in different
versions right in the last couple of
days look
want to be very clear there is a process
here we are going to respect the process
this is all part of the department uh
just the Department of Justice uh
process and we are cooperating fully we
are cooperating fully in this process
and uh again uh the president believes
that the justice department uh and its
independence needs needed to be restored
that's what you have seen under this
Administration the last two years two
years and I want to be consistent in
what I'm saying I want to be prudent in
what I'm saying when I say that we are
going to defer any questions related to
this to the Department of Justice and
any other items that you have if you
don't want to talk to the Department of
Justice you're free to to talk to the
White House counsel office I know you
guys have been in touch with my
colleagues there we have done both but
let me just ask you because oftentimes
in the careers of White House Press
secretaries it becomes there comes a
time where they are asked you know what
they knew and when they knew it were you
or any member your staff involved in the
crafting of a strategy as to when this
disclosure should be made in advance of
CBS News breaking the story on Monday no
good
oh did you have a question
a completely cool questions for you do
you have a position on how high the debt
limit should be raised I don't have a
position on that what I can say more
broadly what wait I mean what I'm saying
is that more broadly speaking not going
to get into the specifics of that what I
can say is that we believe when it comes
to the debt limit it has been done in a
bipartisan way over the years and
decades and it should be done in a
bipartisan way and it should be done
without conditions that is important
here and so we're going to continue to
encourage and ask Congress to take
action and that's where we're going to
leave it at this time we're not going to
do any negotiations or and it should
begin again done without conditions
dollars to Congress and all is this the
legendary
I mean I've said that the ledge our
office of ledge Affairs has been in
touch with the new Congress uh to make
sure that they know who to reach out the
appropriate people to reach out on the
office of ledge Affairs uh and so we're
going to continue we're always having
conversations with members members of
Congress the president always has
multiple conversations with members of
Congress as you know he has a lot of
long time friends who are over uh over
on the other side of of Pennsylvania and
so that is something that continues but
when it comes to this when it comes to
the debt limit it should be done without
conditions it was done under the last
president three times in a bipartisan
way and so this should this should
continue
CPI data yesterday you know pretty good
result there that comes on the heels of
the jobs data which was pretty strong
your officials have been kind of you
know jazzed about that it seems on TV in
the last 24 hours or so uh is it fair to
say the White House is
thinking this is what a soft Landing
could look like or are you not getting
that far
what we can say
I'll say this and as you said you've
heard from many of my colleagues who are
in in the who are economists who have
been working on this issue pushing for
the president's economic plan look it
just goes back to the president's
economic plan and we see it as it's
working right with what the vision that
the president has for this country when
you think about when he came in he
passed the American Rescue plan you
think about all the other historic
pieces of legislation the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation I talked I
talked multiple times and at the top
about the inflation reduction act look
it is it it matters what the vision of a
president is and him acting out on it
and that's what you saw when you see
inflation down for six months uh that
that matters right that's because of the
presence and economic plan when you see
annual inflation down 6.5 percent from
where it was this summer just this
summer at 91.1 percent a gas price is
down by by about more than a buck 70 uh
per from P from its peak all of that
matters and so that's how we're seeing
this we're seeing it as the president's
economic plan is indeed working we are
going to continue to put the American
families and American people first and
work on this issue that you hear us talk
about all the time his number one
economic issue is bringing down
inflation that's why the inflation
reduction act what I talked about when
you think about health care we think
about Medicare and negotiating those
prices when you think about what we
announced in Georgia 2 500 jobs are
going to be created because of the
inflation reduction act all of that all
of that matters and all of that is
important and it's more broadly speaking
about the the present economic plan look
we believe that we continue to be in
this transition of stable and steady
growth and I think that's what we
believe that's what the numbers
continues to show as you talk about the
jobs report that we saw recently and as
you talk as we talk about the CPI data
I'm just I'm just saying that we are in
this transition of a stay transition to
stable and steady growth and we believe
that the economic the presence economic
policies that he's put forward in the
past two years we see that working
good thanks U.S attorney John Locke was
looking into this for for several weeks
uh before he was in touch with looking
into what exactly the classified
documents he was in touch uh with uh
President Biden's Council I wanted to
know was the was President Biden was the
White House surprised that along with uh
with Merrick garland that they decided
that more investigation was needed and a
special counsel was uh was called was
appointed what I can tell you is that we
were not given a heads up uh that the
that attorney general Garland was uh
going to make his made his announcement
yesterday on the special counsel that is
something that we learned like many of
you uh uh watching the news I'm not
going to get into uh into anything
further from that I can't speak to this
person who you just mentioned who has
been I don't know having conversations
or making comments about this I'm just
not going to get into that I'm not going
to re give reactions from here what I
can tell you is that again I'm going to
refer you to the White House Council and
office to talk to my colleagues on any
particular questions that you may have
that's related to this process and if
it's something that you want to know
specifically about the review I refer
you to Department of Justice and Brian
did say you know God willing he hoped to
be able to say more soon I mean it
seemed like he was thinking that the
investigation would end soon was he
surprised I again I'm just not going to
go beyond what the president said I will
say this is that we are we are we are
going to continue to fully cooperate as
I've said we have talked about this at
length we've had multiple statements on
this and again want to be prudent here
I'm going to be consistent here any
questions that you may have about this
process I would refer you to the White
House Council another another topic uh I
wanted to ask about the administration's
appeal of the Sutherland Springs mass
shooting case does it come concern the
administration that some gun control
Advocates are concerned or worried about
the appeal by the doj and that that
appeal undercuts Biden's own stance on
background checks and actually also that
the NRA is essentially applauding the
doj's move so look when it comes to
issues like this legal issues that is
something that the Department of Justice
deals with again they are independent so
I would refer you to them on their
decision the president continues to be
committed on making sure that we address
an issue that is affecting families
across the country communities across
the country which is gun violence that's
why it was so critical when he signed
the bipartisan piece of legislation on
gun violence just a couple of months ago
this past summer and he's going to
continue to call for the ban of assault
weapons working with Congress to make
that happen and let's not forget the
first year and a half of this
Administration we put forwards we put
toward more executive actions than any
other president on dealing with this
issue on dealing with protecting our
communities protecting families dealing
with gun violence and that that is uh
that call that he has especially the
call to action from Congress is going to
continue and it's not going to stop
I'm gonna go to the back okay
um I have two questions on the meeting
with the Prime Minister but just briefly
on the documents we have seen online
propaganda from adversaries seeking to
take advantage from this revolution can
you say can you go back a little bit who
see who's seeking to take advantage we
have seen online propaganda from
adversaries seeking to take advantage of
the revolution of the classified
documents I wonder if you can share with
us whether the administration is
anticipating any kind of National
Security implications from this Fallout
are you hearing any kind of intelligence
and are you doing anything to deter
those threats again I'm just not going
to talk about any intelligence from here
I would certainly anything that's
related to this I would refer you to
Department of Justice and also refer you
to my colleagues at the White House
Council I'm just not going to go into
anything any for especially national
security issue Affairs and so I would
refer you to them I probably follow up
with your National Lottery okay um on
the meeting
um I know we're waiting for a readout
but if you can tell us whether the
leaders spoke about semiconductors and
whether Japan confirmed that it will
enact export controls to limit Chinese
access to semiconductors and whether the
Prime Minister again urged President
Biden as he has done so many times if he
would be open to joining CPT so on cptpp
this is not an option we're exploring I
think we've said that before we're
focused on the ipef as you know the
indo-pacific economic framework
negotiations and deepening our economic
ties with those 13 Partners many of
which are TPP Partners so that is going
to be our Focus that has not changed as
it relates again I wouldn't don't want
to get ahead of the conversation they're
currently still having a dialogue
there's the buy light is still occurring
but I expect they will discuss China
Russia Russia's war against Ukraine and
the dprk's unlawful nuclear and missile
programs and the leaders will focus on
what they can get done together in 2023
Japan holds in the G7 presidency and has
just taken a non-permanent seat on the
U.N security Council while we're hosting
the Apec and seeking to make shift
progress on the indo-pacific economic
framework prime minister kashida arrived
at the White House as you all know I
believe my colleague laid out what came
out of that two plus two after
Consulting closely with us and Regional
Partners in in Europe and I expect the
president and the Prime Minister kashida
will will debrief on those consultations
again don't want to get ahead of we're
going to have a readout for you they're
having this conversation currently and
so once we have the readout this
afternoon we certainly will share that I
can just dig a little bit deeper on iPad
because we really haven't heard much
about this framework since it was
launched last year so at this point it
seems like the administration still
believes that this is the best offer
that the U.S can give to counter Chinese
trade cloud is that am I understanding
this correctly let me just so as you
said it was announced in Tokyo just this
past May
um and uh and Japan was a critical
partner as you know in helping us to
build support particularly among
Southeast Asian countries so that is
important again Japan has been a
critical partner in this uh ipf Partners
represent 40 percent of the world GDP
and we are united in our belief that
much of our success in coming in coming
decades will depend on how well
governments harness Innovation so that
is part of it right we got to see how
this works through especially the
transformations of foot in the clean
energy digital technology sectors while
fortifying our economies against a rage
of threats from fragile Supply chains to
corruption to tax Havens so again with
Japan's Partnerships and leadership in
the negotiations we expect to achieve
high standard uh commitments that will
deepen our our economic engagement in
the region and make good progress in
text based negotiations this year so
this is a partnership that is incredibly
important Japan played a very big role
in it when you think about it represents
the 40 percent of the world GDP uh and
so look this is again an important
partnership this is a framework that we
are incredibly committed to and we
appreciate Japan's partnership in this
yeah yeah
um yeah thanks great I want to ask you
about the U.S Chamber of Commerce so the
U.S Chamber of Commerce embraced
President Biden in 2020 and now the
President of the U.S Chamber says that
the businesses it represents are fed up
with the government making it harder to
do business and adding new rules and
regulations you have any responses yes I
do um first thing the president's first
two years in office have been the the
best for job creation in history when
you think about 10.5 nearly 10.5 million
jobs created manufacturing and small
businesses are on the rise and we are
seeing progress in our fight against
Global inflation so so that's the first
piece to uh to just lay out there the
second uh look I don't think that it's
all uh all of the chambers presidents
who said that she also called out
polarization and gridlock and called for
permitting reform immigration reform
improving Child Care improving climate
resilience and funding law enforcement
so those are all areas where president
has called for Congress to act and we
also agree with the chamber that
Congress must address and the debt limit
and we can quote not play chicken with
the true faith and credit of the United
States that's end quote and and lastly
let me just say as I think everyone is
aware the last two years showed historic
bipartisan progress for the American
people I've talked about in this and
during this uh press during this press
briefing those pieces of legislation
again historic pieces of legislation
including on rebuilding our
infrastructure and investing in American
manufacturing so the president's plans
on infrastructure Next Generation
research clean energy and Manufacturing
are strongly supported by business
Community again you know we do Outreach
to different communities when we talk
about these important pieces of
legislation where we talk about the
president's economic plan but he also
believes big corporations should pair
should pay their fair share in taxes and
that's not just us that's also the
American public who believes that they
should be doing this well she said also
that there's government um regulatory
overreach adding and they'll quote her
when regulations are driven by
ideological agendas and imposing imposed
on businesses without transparency
accountability or Clarity government
isn't working so will there be changes
in its government work I'll say this our
Administration is leveraging every
available tool to advance the
president's ambitious agenda for the
country and to deliver the American
people that's the president's primary
goal when he comes when he came into the
administration and it continues to be
the case he wanted to make sure that
he's delivering for the American people
delivering for American families making
sure that we building an economy from
the bottom up middle out and that's what
you are seeing I was just asked about
the inflation data the CPI data and the
jobs report we are seeing while there's
still more work to do we are seeing the
economic the president's economic policy
is actually working okay uh go ahead
Alex in the back uh yeah Queen earlier
this week we discussed the situation in
Florida where I think about 350 cubic
migrants landing at a dry Tortuga and
Key West I believe you you said uh it
was a political Ploy on the part of of
Governor DeSantis to deploy the National
Guard his office has said that the Coast
Guard requested help patrolling the
waters off Florida who can you just kind
of discuss your understanding of the
situation uh in Florida and how that how
that understanding has developed in the
last summer and I'm going to be and I'm
happy to repeat what I said which is
Governor DeSantis has made a mockery of
uh of the system and uh and he has
consistently and constantly as many of
you have reported uh has done political
stunts has not helped to address the
issue but has instead decided to put the
lives of migrants who are coming here
for a better life at risk and that's
what we have seen from this Governor
look when it comes to the Coast Guard
and Customs and Border Protection they
are deploying additional personnel and
resources to Florida to quickly process
individuals and place them in removal
proceedings I would note that the
migrants from Cuba were who arrived in
Florida over a week ago were processed
and moved out of the state by border
patrol within days uh the at the
national park that you mentioned it
reopened just this past Sunday the
president has expanded safe orderly
legal Pathways for migration including
for Cubans and we continue to urge
individuals to to use those instead of
risking their lives at the hands of
human human strugglers and you heard
that directly from this President just a
couple of days ago on the world stage in
Mexico City
I'm going to try and call folks I
haven't go ahead Karen folks I haven't
called it um
you've several times today referred
people to the White House Council for
questions about the process and the
review would you bring Richard Sauber
here with someone from his team to
answer these questions in the briefing
room in a formal so look the White House
council's office has provided
information uh on this uh this week as
appropriate uh again I think I just said
this I've said this multiple times
during this briefing that I know in the
last 24 hours my colleagues at the White
House Council has been a White House
consulate office has been in touch with
many of you and has answered a lot of
your questions and so uh that will
continue you reach out to them and they
will they will certainly engage and so
I'm going to leave it there but again I
will anything that is related to this
review I would I would send you to
Department of Justice again if if there
is something specific uh to uh to this
that you want from us I would refer to
the White House Council off and is the
White House concerned that this
investigation is going to overshadow
what you are trying to do right now what
your message is right now look our
message is very clear and it will
continue to to uh to be uh just that and
you've seen it that's why when I started
the briefing I laid out all of the uh um
all of the kind of progress that we have
made just this week alone when you think
about the inflation reduction act when
you think about how it's going to lower
cost for our American families when you
think about the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation just recently
as you all some of you were there in
Kentucky where you saw a bipartisanship
uh talking about a bridge that has for
decades for decades presidents have
talked about fixing that bridge and this
President because of the bipartisanship
that he was able to bring together got
that done and so look we're not going to
stop talking about how we're going to
deliver for the American people I
actually think and we actually believe
there are uh there are people who are
watching the American people are
watching want to hear that they want to
hear what I just laid out at the
beginning of the briefing they want to
know how this President how this
Administration how the federal
government is delivering for them so
again we're going to continue to have
those conversations you're going to
continue to hear from me speaking about
that you heard from the President
yesterday talking about the CPI data and
how important it was to see inflation go
down in six six months and how we're
seeing record low unemployment in 50
years that is conversation and that work
is going to continue thanks everybody
[Music]